huh st. Patty's Day good times today is
the day when all of us channel our inner
Irishmen and get blackout drunk on green
beer at the bar I mean it's it's awesome
but while all of my friends are out
there doing just that I'm gonna be
indulging in some sweets because one of
the things I've learned recently that I
love is that my little leprechaun loves
the sugar we have a little dance party
every single night after a treat and let
me tell you today is going to be no
different because I'm gonna be making my
gluten-free vegan chocolate mint
cupcakes that are super delicious for
st. Patty's Day because there's some
green in there but also really festive
for any time of year so you're gonna
love this recipe let's do this first I
make a flax egg by combining some ground
flax seed with some unsweetened almond
milk and giving it a good stir then I
pop it into the refrigerator for 15
minutes to set up next to a bowl I add
some almond flour coconut flour cocoa
powder baking soda and salt and I give
it a quick stir then I add my flax egg
some melted vegan butter maple syrup and
mint extract and I give that a good stir
till it all comes together
finally I fold in some dairy-free dark
chocolate shavings before portioning it
into some lined muffin tins pop it into
the oven at three and fifty degrees for
about 20 to 24 minutes and let's make
our frosting for a frosting I whip
together some vegan butter with lots of
powdered sugar and then a little bit of
natural green food coloring now it's
time to decorate once the cupcakes have
cooled down I topped them off with a
really generous portion of that vegan
buttercream and then top everything off
with some chocolate sprinkles and vegan
chocolate shavings enjoy
[Music]
well guys I hope you enjoy my recipe for
my vegan gluten-free chocolate mint
cupcakes I know I definitely enjoyed
mine and my baby ditto seriously we've
been kicking off the storm for the past
hour so I hope you loved this video if
you did be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below some of your
favorite st. Patty's Day treats what are
some of the great green things in your
life that you totally love leave me a
comment below about some of your
favorite st. Patty's Day treats and all
the great green foods that are out there
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]
you
[Music]